[Musique]
terrebonne jean pierre à 53 ans est une
passion qu'il oblige à prendre un soin
tout particulier de ses chaussures j'ai
pas le physique on en attend du cliché
du danseur de claquettes son métier est
bien éloignée du monde de la scène et de
la comédie qui le font tant rêver il est
professeur d'anglais à l'université de
clermont-ferrand grosse base
jean pierre a déjà voyagé en europe mais
il a décidé de franchir un nouveau pas
il va se rendre aux états unis le pays
référence dans le monde des claquettes
j'ai eu un passeport à 18 ans je me suis
jamais servir je vais m'en servir pour
la première fois c'est
quelque chose à quelques heures du
départ il a du mal à cacher son anxiété
au cros perdrait
[Musique]
c'est le jour du départ la valise
lourdes et le coeur un peu serré jean
pierre a du mal à réaliser
s'il connaît bien la culture américaine
à travers sa passion et son métier il
n'est encore jamais allé aux états unis
[Musique]
j'ai déjà là bah ouais faire des
claquettes parce que c'est super c'est
un pays les claquettes c'est tellement
important qu'ils ont un nationale tap
dance bay et un jour officiel des
claquettes là bas
de new york à los angeles son voyage va
lui faire découvrir deux villes parmi
les plus visités du monde et qui sont
aussi les plus utilisés comme décor de
cinéma
jean-pierre les connaît déjà un peu même
sans jamais y avoir mis les pieds
[Musique]
c'est génial d'être un tueur de te voir
pour de vrai ce que j'ai vu dans tous
ses films
mais dans les films c'est pâques où la
réalité
[Musique]
roxane
ok oui
c'est un plaisir connaissant
rien
15h24
c'est gratuit
ces chemises et la foule
impressionnant
et avait vu des comédies musicales en
france qui venait dit si roxane est la
référence française des claquettes à new
york elle a travaillé avec les plus
grands qu'est ce qui fait que tu sois
aujourd'hui à new york j'avais claquette
mais j'en ai fait j'en ai vu qu en
europe pour l'instant mais c'est vrai
qu'ici c'est la mecque des claquettes
est ce que représente cette image de
brevets à l'étranger c'est ça c'est le
rêve américain la comédie musicale
toute cette culture là qui est
typiquement des 6es
et voilà donc avec bienvenue dans ce
monde
a ironisé billets pas allées venues
entre new york et est partie
officiellement du paysage new york et
manor un gentil là c'est plus de la
blague c'est vrai de vrai
on va sculpter
à l'erreur ce qu'il fait
2 israël est utile et a gagné à des
petits avec des claquettes
porté par sa passion jean pierre ne
résiste pas à l'envi de chausser ses
claquettes pour faire ses premiers pas
de danse sur le sol américain
sa maison tout cas à
[Applaudissements]
bravo c'est très bien merci
wodié est ce que tu es belle claquette
ce que j'aime c'est le son que ça fait
c'est clic clac clic clac
et aussi j'adore les sensations que ça
procure quand je fais tout ça
l'epa et la façon d'y plaquer et bien
continue comme ça et tu seras un grand
danseur
j'étais bien sorti avec du talent comme
ça pour vous
là comme ça
bouge toujours c'est toujours à 100 on
va bon sens alors surtout par rapport à
la province veille a clairement ce que
je vois des eaux l'étape déguisés comme
16 elles sont pas créé tellement ce
serait sympathique on est à clermont
ferrand il faut il faudrait des fesses
trop imposant
ce soir roxane va jouer dans un
spectacle avec un des grands
claquettistes du moment
elle doit faire une dernière répétition
elle a convié jean pierre à y assister
max polak à apporter de la modernité
dans une discipline surtout lié jusqu'à
présent au jazz et aux musiques au
j'étais amené une surprise c'est
jean-pierre un fan qui vient de france
bonjour je suis fière
et ravie d'être rencontrés
génial merci d'être venus max tu
travailles sur quoi entre mois
là en ce moment je travaille sur mon
prochain disque il va s'appeler rumba
tap j'ai très envie de vous montrer
c'est incroyable incroyable
j'ai jamais rien vu de tel
tu vas vraiment un style unique
[Applaudissements]
moi de répondre
il ya vraiment des élèves entre eux c
[Applaudissements]
on a un coup d'éclat qu'une compagnie
aigle azur
n'étaient pas retirées à percussion
corporelle je le redis john dans cette
banale en choisir un endroit qui fera
date
fini les répétitions place au vrai
spectacle
jean-pierre accompagne les deux artistes
vers la salle où ils se produisent ce
soir sur la 42e rue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'auvergne et clermont ferrand semble
désormais bien loin
jean-pierre se sent presque adopté par
la grosse pomme pour mieux l'apprécier
il s'est même offert un baptême en
hélicoptère au dessus des buildings
new-yorkais
[Musique]
et pour se remettre de ses émotions et
mieux reprendre pied sur le plancher des
vaches rien de tel qu'un passage par une
des meilleures adresses gastronomiques
de la ville
[Musique]
c'est le temps pédiode dogues ici
grand spécialiste de signer au régime on
prend juste à saucisse à 290 calories
messieurs on a vraiment faim les frites
avec vue chimie et du fromage or un
petit 1390 calories et voilà un petit
snack à l'américaine le maïs et surtout
le hot dog et baba d'aboutir
[Musique]
ces américains c'est bien gras
mais temps en temps ça va
[Musique]
cela fait deux jours que jean pierre est
arrivé cet après midi il doit prendre un
cours de claquettes avec roxane
le rendez vous est fixé dans un des plus
beaux studio danse de greenwich village
où elle enseigne régulièrement
pour l'occasion jean pierre a pris des
chaussures sur lesquelles il a pris soin
de monter de nouveau faire
ok
bienvenue en pierre merci encore à new
york
bienvenue à tous et donc un tour niveau
intermédiaire n'est ce pas yes
[Musique]
chabadabada un des ports dvi de l'autre
côté
à droite selon le vol est ce que vous
devez éviter c'est ça ce qu'il faut
faire c'est ça comme si quelqu'un vous
poussait au niveau des hanches 3x à plat
[Musique]
la
dalle est
[Musique]
allez on reprend depuis le début ja
bompas d'edo pas ça va dégager le ton
s'est durci cette équipe c'est dur quand
on découvre une nouvelle tout petit peu
tâté inconnue une partie mais c'est du
miel justement de voir s c'est nouveau
c'est un rythme rapide en secours ou
intermédiaire d'ici et russe avancé en
france thiès d'aller
voir à a vraiment sa
voix la marque hockey à
et à l'oeil à et à et et
ayasse à et
[Musique]
gauche a et aa et
ness et à et
[Applaudissements]
autonome félicitations à jean pierre
lorsqu'il avait été vraiment formidable
je suis vraiment fier de toi
un acte d'héroïsme de courage york
termine là il ya des profs enfin depuis
30 ans 3 donc c'était super un africain
je crois qu'on peut encore là peut dire
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant de quitter new york jean-pierre
entend bien assister à une comédie
musicale sur broadway
roxane lui a conseillé un américain à
paris un clin d'oeil à la venue de
l'auvergnat sur les rives de l'hudson
une des amies de roxane joue sur scène
c'est même une des vedettes du spectacle
et roxanne veut lui présenter jean
pierre
et sauf
là
bonjour pavane bonjour tenir
oui on chantait
alors tapis si
tu as aimé oui
c'est un beau mélange les danseurs
doivent être capables de faire des
claquettes du ballet et chanter oui et
tout ça en même temps
et on m'a dit que vous étiez un super
danseur de claquettes ou bien ces temps
de crise je suis un fan des claques et
tu fais avec la quête depuis combien de
temps il m'a dit oui depuis très très
longtemps vingt ans peut-être et tu
chantes aussi aussi j'ai fait un peu de
chose et tu fais du bellay non non non
malheureusement
on va le garder un américain à paris va
devenir le français à new york
c'est quoi ton prochain rêve après celui
là ce serait non c'est pas encore il
faudrait y réfléchissent moi je pense
que tu dois profiter de chaque instant
ici à new york et puis après tu
trouveras bien autrement eh oui ne
t'inquiète pas ça va venir des villes du
jour elle va sans dire
savary argent si sûr et merci pour ce
moment magique encore
merci mon dieu
mon plaisir est très très bien
[Musique]
les yeux remplis d'étoilés
jean pierre vit un moment unique
[Musique]
rock ça lui a permis de découvrir new
york broadway et de rencontrer quelques
danseurs qui compte parmi les stars des
claquettes
il a pu se rendre compte que dans ce
pays tout le monde pouvait tenter sa
chance et jouer son numéro il va
poursuivre son voyage vers la californie
à los angeles jean pierre espère bien
croiser le chemin de celle qui l'a
poussé vers les claquait une tête
d'affiche de la célèbre comédie musicale
fame
[Musique]
sur les trottoirs d'hollywood boulevard
les étoiles sont sans doute encore plus
brillante qu'ailleurs
jean pierre a toutes les raisons
d'apprécier les états unis qu'il ait dû
attendre cinquante trois ans pour venir
en amérique est presque un paradoxe
c'est un 4 juillet qu'il découvre la
cité des anges 4 juillet le jour de la
fête nationale ici
mais aussi le jour de son anniversaire
[Musique]
bonne fête d'indépendance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
calvin et quoi c'est mon anniversaire
aujourd'hui bonne anniversaire merci
c'est la première fois que je dis aux
états unis c'était aussi mon
anniversaire c'est ton anniversaire mais
aujourd'hui bonne anniversaire merci
c'est la première visite aux états unis
et c'est un jour spécial c'est mon
anniversaire aujourd'hui un joyeux
anniversaire merci j'aurais dû être un
mérite et antoine oui
a new york les gens sont sympas mais ils
sont plus stressés tandis que là c'est
mal il faut déduire willaxxx
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la parade je crois qu'ils en aient
mais les chevaux il faut bâtir des
claquettes la grâce amour
[Applaudissements]
après les festivités de l'indépendance
day jean-pierre veut surtout profiter de
son voyage pour rencontrer une légende
une idole pour lui la star de la série
fame une série culte des années 80 dont
il connaît par coeur tous les épisodes
qui racontait l'histoire de jeunes
danseurs répétant dur pour réaliser
leurs rêves
la professeure intransigeante été jouée
par debbie allen
depuis debbie allen a monté à los
angeles sa propre école de danse
très occupé elle a quand même accordé un
peu de son précieux temps à jean pierre
[Musique]
bonjour jean pierre bonjour bonjour
vous êtes tellement célèbre en france
ces gens france depuis fame
a fait si beau
dans la série fame vous incarniez un
prof de danse
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de vous dans ce
personnage
le personnage me correspondait à peu
près à 80 % d'accord 20% du rôle n'était
pas moi
j'adore danser j'adore du music hall
mais les claquettes cet esprit
oui les claquettes c'est important
et tous mes élèves s'y met c'est un
course essentiel offre ayant des plus
populaires
et à dater je pense que les claquettes
connecte les danseurs avec le rythme et
le timing
c'est une histoire de taille et des
espaces
papa ricky lac est une bonne base pour
le t tout passe par le timing si vous
avez compris ça vous avez tout compris
est ce qu'il ya un secret pour être un
grand danseur
il n'y a pas un seul secret des mérides
tous les grands danseurs ont leurs
propres différences et les ont tous leur
propre adn
certains sont très aérien ça me verrais
d'autres danses avec intensité la benne
on vous devine pas la chose la plus
importante c'est le coeur guen il faut
toujours les côtés et dense est toujours
au delà de nos propres l'once il faut
dans ces vers l'infini danser avec de
l'élégance
très bien
merci beaucoup merci à vous prenez un
cours ici à l'occasion
oui merci beaucoup
je vous en prie
on veut c'est impressionnant de l'avoir
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
personnalité puis
très connue et elle a changé mais pas
tant que ça finalement dans son visage a
toujours cette même
force en vrai dans sa gestuelle et ou
qu'elle est toujours la fois hélas le
dynamisme du danseur en l2 ça aspire de
voir cette énergie parce qu'on peut se
dire que qu'à tout âge
et puis à tout moment on peut se lancer
des défis
fermés dans cette boîte aller au delà
dire qu'est ce que je vais faire demain
il trouva lendemain et vous vous défier
qu'il soit challenge c'est ça qui fait
avancer je pense
c'est un jour de chance pour jean-pierre
l'école de debbie allen abrite aussi
d'autres célébrités dans la salle
voisine un professeur hors norme donne
un cours de claquettes
avec ses airs de punk jason samuel smith
est un des artistes les plus doués de sa
génération
son style est unique pour jean-pierre
l'occasion est belle de vérifier que le
monde des claquettes est loin d'être
vieillot
ça pour présenter les claquettes
d'aujourd'hui cité merci merci
les pieds sont des instruments partout
et tu veux exprimer sa propre culture ta
propre musique ta propre histoire
personnelle
tu peux le faire en faisant des
claquettes
c'est pourquoi les gens du monde entier
se tournent vers cette danse l'utilisent
pour raconter leur propre histoire
c'est ça mec juste vouloir s'exprimer
avoir une conversation comme nous
faisons maintenant on va faire ça
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
à
[Rires]
merci beaucoup
d'avoir danse avec toi mec
[Musique]
il ya un brin de nostalgie parce que le
séjour est finie et mémoire
les souvenirs sont toujours pleins la
tête et le coeur voyager c'est
ses rêvés pour de vrai puis dans la vie
aussi faut avoir des rêves justement et
créative aller plus loin à fortis
objectif donc choisi relâche en train de
faire ça mais vivre au jour le jour mais
vivre dans le raid de l'avenir de ce que
je peux faire de mieux
[Musique]
jean pierre espère profiter de son
aventure américaine pour réveiller le
monde des claquettes en france à son
retour lui redonné les couleurs qu'ils
méritent
son voyage a été une étincelle une
occasion peut-être de faire évoluer
différemment le cours de sa vie
[Musique]